[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going to be filling
in a large gap not like a construction
project but kind of a large it's got
that magnitude two gap in our past that
we're calling The Lost years yeah and I
say it's it's a large magnitude I really
don't know if to the listener and how
they're gonna process this or how much
they're gonna be interested but for us
this is a really big deal you know
there's there's many parts of our
journey of how we got to where we are
right now that we've told many times I
mean we we've told a lot of stories a
lot of times how we met on the first day
of first grade bub above blah who told
that story a lot we told the story about
how we first got on YouTube that we had
a website so we didn't think we needed
YouTube somebody stole a video we made
called pimp my stroller put it on
YouTube and that's how that started well
and the question that we get that the
the story that has been told repeatedly
in multiple interviews multiple articles
is okay rhett and Link you guys were
engineers and then you stopped being
engineers and you became full-time
youtubers and that is a very simple
story that is not exactly true I
wouldn't say this I wouldn't say that
it's it's it was it's a lie it's just
not the whole truth and I would think
that's surprising because in the over
the more than a decade of us talking to
you about us and so many stories about
our shared past you'd think we would
have shared everything there is to share
but there is some there is there's a big
part and there's a lot of details that
we've never shared before and I would go
hey we are going to share and I would go
as far as to say is that these details
and you'll understand
in a second why they haven't been shared
and why we're sharing them now
I think they constitute ironically the
most significant
reason that we are who we are today and
we're doing what we do today and and
what and the true story of how we got to
be doing this weird job a full-time the
two of us from North Carolina small town
North kind of got to where we're doing
this job right now we have this aspect
of the story is really the reason that
we're doing it is the how we got to be
rhett and Link yeah we got to be
professional entertainers yeah and we've
never connected those dots okay so the
glaring question at this point is well
why haven't you talked about this before
why haven't you shared this if this if
this is such a big deal this is why
you're doing what you're doing right now
why have you never talked about it
because you talked about everything else
multiple multiple times and there's a
complicated why we're talking about it
now and then we'll talk about why we
haven't talked about open to now okay
the overwhelming momentum of this
podcast this podcast I think is the main
reason the overwhelming moan momentum
has been a move towards the personal you
know I've been sharing about going to
therapy and the stuff that I've been
dealing with in therapy links been
sharing about the stuff he's been going
through with relatives illnesses and
grandfather's dying I've been crying on
this y'all daughters getting surgery
yeah and it's gotten so increasingly
personal which isn't something that we
ever really intended just kind of just
happened once you sit down and talk to
each other for a few years that it
became it started to become almost
uncomfortable that we had not really
delved into what we're going to talk
about because you start to dance around
those things and it's I mean it's not
that we feel like we owe this story to
anybody but I feel like it's been a
rewarding experience to use as we've
taught it before to use the ear biscuits
as a venue for us to process our
friendship and our lives with the
with each other and if people find
benefit in that then that's that's great
as an added you know as a side side
effect of this being something that we
enjoying this rewarding for us I will
also say that I I do remember when we
were when we were doing the interview
part of your biscuits and we would like
really drill into people's personal
lives felt a little it imbalanced
because we knew that there was a part
there was a section of our lives that we
we just weren't ready to talk about
right but we always approach talking to
other people with the assumption that
well maybe they're not ready but we can
get them ready to talk about it and that
just didn't in retrospect it I don't
think it was fair I agree with that and
I do think that's a a small contributing
factor to this but so I I'm excited I'm
a little nervous I think my heart rates
a little higher than a normal look at
your look at your watch tell me I have
no heart rate it's over they're dead so
the reason that we haven't shared this
these lost years is because they are
very much tied to our past in terms of
our spiritual and religious history
yeah I'd say our religious upbringing
our spiritual past and so you might have
immediately start to guess okay I I have
my guesses I can I can get why they
wouldn't have talked about this it's a
personal topic and it's not that we've
never shared in if you you can find you
write search on the internet and come to
some conclusions and find some
information about this it's not that
we've been completely locked out about
this but I think in general we've just
avoided talking about religion in
general because it's a super divisive
topic just like politics happen to be
and that isn't tip this isn't the space
that we typically discussed those kinds
of things we our brand so to speak is
super inclusive and not the kind it's
not there's so much opportunity for
people to get divided as soon as you
start talking about anything as personal
as religion or politics and we value the
opposite of division right unity
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I mean it's also
we felt that it hasn't been necessary to
share it I mean we thought it could have
been taken the wrong way it could serve
as a distraction from potentially from
what we were trying to do which is be
entertainers you know to be comedians to
to connect with an audience in a way
that just brings light into their lives
but we thought it might be a distraction
from that it's also those are some of
the reasons also it's in interviews
whenever we would kind of sidestep the
question because we'd always get the
question of like what was it like to
quit engineering and become youtubers or
how that how did you decide to go all-in
on entertainment in this this fledgling
platform where nobody knew what was
going on or if you'd ever make it you
had kids and it wasn't practical to
answer that question with well let me
tell you the very non circuitous or
circuitous path that we took yeah it's
not a soundbite it's not a soundbite
it's not an easy answer in fact the
answer itself when given in hole kind of
becomes a story in and of itself and
that wasn't the story that we were being
interviewed about that may sound a
little complicated but it's just because
the story isn't clean it's not clean it
gotta goes in a lot of different places
and that's the story that we're gonna
tell today we're going to share that
dirty story today but I think another
reason which is opens up a whole other
can of worms which we will also get into
and that's overtime our personal beliefs
have been evolving we've been in process
so as we've had Inklings of wanting to
talk about things and share about them
it's like well everything is in flux
right and I don't know if that's an
exaggeration to say everything because I
think that's probably pretty accurate
everything's been in flux well stated
simply when we started YouTube in 2006
we would have described ourselves as
evangelical Christians and I'll explain
what we mean by that in a second and
that is not how we would describe
ourselves now and
20 robbed so I mean at certain points
when we describe ourselves that way we
also knew that if you just if you if you
label yourself it attracts people
putting their expectations and their
assumptions on that label then on to you
and then good bad or indifferent it in
in the least we were we feared it would
be a distraction from just how we were
simply trying to be entertainers and to
connect with an audience but but it
could we perceive that it could have
been even more troublesome than that and
then as our as a our personal believes
evolved it became even more complicated
and it was okay
I don't want there's certain certain
aspects of what certain people might
associate with a label that I don't want
to be associated with you know let's
continue to not talk about this yeah so
that now because we're talking about it
today does that mean that we've arrived
some personal spiritual journey and
therefore we're ready to share all the
conclusions and wisdom that we've come
to we've come out the other side of
something and now we're ready to talk
about it
no that's also not the case right no I
think that I do think that there has
been a certain process that has taken
place that has we now have kind of
cutted some clues some conclusions about
who we were at the time hmm that I think
does make it kind of easier to talk
about and kind of it also just kind of
understanding and becoming more
comfortable with our past and and and
the process that we've been through and
it's something that we talk about a lot
personally the two of us is something we
talk about with our friends a lot we
have not and also comfortable enough
with where we are right now and I'm I'm
talking about from a spiritual faith
perspective not that we've arrived at
anything but that were comfortable
having not arrived speaking about it
here
in a way where we can we can foster some
sort of conversation yeah not only
between the two of us but with with you
as you listen yeah so okay so what is
this gonna look like so today we're
gonna talk we're gonna tell we're gonna
talk about the lost years we're gonna
fill in that gap between basically
starting in high school and coming all
the way up to 2006 when we started our
YouTube channel I'm really getting into
what especially did it look like in
college and after college and
engineering and all the other stuff that
happened yeah I would say for that part
it's it's this by the way we have we
have notes that's if you hear those if
you're listening or if you're watching
us on the video version you see these
yeah we usually don't have any notes we
have so much there we've got dates and
you know the order and we wanted to get
the details right so that's why we're
gonna be referencing some of this stuff
so we're what we're trying to do is
we're trying to outline a multiple
episode plan of attack for how we're
gonna roll out the things we want to
talk about so like Rhett said in this
episode we're gonna connect on the dot
all the dots on how he actually got to
where we are now and I think that's the
story of how two boys who made a blood
oath to create something together gave
up that dream studied engineering
instead but then gave up those careers
to become Christian missionaries instead
and then somehow achieve their boyhood
dream anyways that's the journey that we
want to take you through today and then
in the in the next couple of weeks
because we're gonna talk about this for
a while again I don't know how you're
gonna take this some of you are gonna be
like oh I've been waiting for you guys
to talk about this forever so you know
why are you talking about it right
forever but we're gonna talk about it
and so this week we fill in the gaps and
then the next couple of weeks we're
actually going to tell our individual
personal stories of kind of how we got
to where we're at our you know we share
a lot in common but the stories are very
personal and individual at the same time
so we thought we should yeah we should
talk about it from a purse
individual perspective so we're each
gonna do that so that's gonna get that's
gonna be more the like spiritual
religious belief yeah
personal journey evolution type stuff
and then we're gonna just see where it
goes after that and we invite you guys
to get involved in the conversation
using hash tag ear biscuits if you have
questions that come up comments thoughts
opinions as we tell our story we want to
hear from you we want you to be a part
of the conversation and then you know
we're not saying that the podcast is
changing and now it's all about this no
but for a few episodes this is what it's
gonna be about as we kind of dig into
this and explore it yeah these three and
then I think we'll be looking at where
the conversation goes on the hash tag
ear biscuits and it I anticipate later
down the road we might skip a few
episodes and then come back to
responding to the conversations that are
being had around these three episodes so
hash tag your biscuits for that but
we're gonna get into the Lost years but
first we're gonna let you know that you
can buy links t-shirt because that's
that's what we do
well it's how we pay for this it's
interesting because this t-shirt like
what we're gonna talk about today is
gonna make sense of this t-shirt this is
this is me in college dancing right in a
70s outfit I remember I wasn't there but
I know where you were and why you were
there
dance like no one's watching I know all
the contexts that led up to that moment
and I felt I felt weird wins like they
dug up this photo and they wanted to put
it on a shirt I thought it was funny but
then I was also like yeah but I've never
talked about why that why I was dancing
like this well could you were dancing I
was just dancing but a lot of people
were watching you can get that shirt
that link is a little bit embarrassed
about four reasons I guess I'll go into
at mythical dot-com along with all kinds
of other cool mythical things rep you
boys mythical calm all right where do we
want to start well I said a second ago
that I I thought that it was important
to define what we mean by
angelical christian because i think that
that may mean a lot of different things
to a lot of different people but i just
want you all to understand exactly who
we were and what we thought what we
believe because i think that's a good
starting point so to us being an
evangelical christian meant that we
believed that the Bible was the Word of
God meaning the creator of the universe
chose to communicate the breadth of his
wisdom through a book that he inspired
people to write it's called the Bible
the Old Testament the New Testament and
in the Bible you learn about Jesus who
is the son of God and he is the only way
that you can have a right relationship
with God and then one day end up being
in heaven and what that essentially
means is that if you don't go to Jesus
if you don't believe in Jesus if Jesus
has not forgiven you of your sins then
you basically face judgment of your sins
and you're going to when you die you're
going to face God's judgment that's
called hell and so everybody on earth
who does not put their faith in Jesus so
if you come from a different religion
too bad you're not gonna be with God in
the end that that is essentially that is
essentially the sort of the theological
view that that we had and a lot of
people do have and the word evangelical
to me brings to mind the the component
of wanting to then convert people right
because if you believe that then you
want people to be there with that you
you should be motivated by that to
persuade to inform people and if not
persuade them to put their faith in
Jesus so that they can be saved because
evangelism is basically sharing the good
news sharing the gospel sharing that
truth that without Jesus people are
going to be judged and so you want to
tell as many people about Jesus as you
can and you want your life to be
representative of that truth so we grew
up
in an environment in a church that
wholeheartedly believe this I mean we
actually took you back in the the buoys
Buies Creek documentary that's on good
mythical morning we showed you booze
Creek First Baptist Church where we both
grew up when you move there in first
grade and we met at school we were both
going to that church and and it was a
big part of our lives and a big like all
of our closest closest friends we've
been our closest friends closest friends
Yeah right so it was what it was our
world it was our it was what oriented
everything that we thought and did and
of course as we got older and kind of
became teenagers you know I think that
when you're in that environment as you
become a teenager people kind of take a
couple of different paths some people
are like oh if this is true then this is
the most important thing that there is
if there really is the spiritual reality
and there really is this eternity that
people need to make a decision about
this is way more important than girls
than sports than academics than where
I'm gonna go to college and what I'm
gonna do this is the preeminent truth
where that affects every single decision
that I make and that is something that
started to permeate us very deeply in
high school yeah and I I think be good
to skipped to the wax paper dog yeah at
this point that's a good example of we
were in high school we you know there
was there was a church split so like we
there was actually we started a group of
family started a brand new church from
scratch right my mom and I came over
basically because like like we trusted
you and your your family and what you
know the fact that they were
instrumental in that
and then from from that church there was
a an outreach created where it was
called the Maranatha cafe it was like a
coffee shop on the edge of Campbell
University so that Campbell University
College students could come over and
hang out in a Christian coffee
environment
I don't know that Christian coffee
tasted any different
and I actually don't remember there
being much coffee but it was like a
hangout there's the idea of coffee and
it was it was Benny ands ORS brainchild
who his sons Matt and John were like we
grew up with them you're like good
friends of ours from like kindergarten
yeah yeah I mean it's first grade yeah
and his vision was that it was a
performance space there was a stage in
the back and they had an open mic night
and so people from the college could
come and play at the open mic night you
know you got you got the whole hippie
vibe and the the coffee shop at 5:00
welcome init and just the idea that
there was a stage there was an
opportunity to get on that stage and
perform for an audience you know we had
just kind of you know dipped our toes
into performing doing simple things like
just doing a class in speech or doing a
video in front of the class and being
the class clowns and so the icing you
down with Halloweens act all festival
that you know Fall Festival talent show
that kind of thing so this was already
in our blood and so when they were like
we're gonna have this cafe college
students are gonna show up yeah we were
like well of course we gotta start a
band and I think just this is this is a
theme that's gonna be throughout all of
these dots that we're connecting is
whenever we see that there's an audience
we we try to find a way to get in front
of that audience right so yeah we were
like let's form a band
can we play any instruments nano
Vinnie's son John was learning the bass
I think he's I think he started it from
a musical perspective Vinnie's son Matt
was into like the sound board Eric was
learning the guitar
mium you couldn't play anything right
and then we didn't have a drummer and
then Benny said oh y'all want to start a
band I'll help you out he was he he was
multi-instrumentalist right he played
the piano at the church actually yes
so he started playing keyboards in our
band which we called the wax paper dogs
we called it
wax paper dogs because the previous
summer it just so happened everybody
that was in the band was in a whitewater
raft that was going down the some river
at the end of a mission trip you know
when you're gonna church mission trip at
the end of the mission trip you gotta
have some fun
we went whitewater rafting and we called
our raft the leopard we were gonna call
him the paper dogs we said well the
paper gets wet it disintegrates and is
wrapped in the river right so we got to
make it wax paper so we called our group
the wax paper dogs we were just a
rafting rapo rafting group just so
heaven everybody was in that boat
including Benny yeah the dad was in this
band so we called the band the wax paper
dogs and we started practicing we spent
we spent so much time going in the
Maranatha cafe when it was closed
because was Benny basically was the
prior to the place and had the key we'd
go in there and just we would we play
and learn songs and practice for hours
and hours it became it became the thing
that we were most passionate about yeah
well I would say that you know Benny is
a human going to be basically pointing
out a number of really instrumental
people who kind of played these really
really pivotal roles and getting us to
where we're at now and I think Benny is
one of the very is one of the very first
yes not only was the Maranatha Cafe his
idea his brainchild and he was the one
that put all the work into it
but we would have never had a band
without him I would have never learned
to play the guitar without him we would
have never understood songwriting
without him and so many of the things
that became sort of the foundational
elements of our career even when once
we've got a YouTube we were doing mostly
music it all started with Benny's vision
and it was influence it was weird
because he's is he's an old dude but
like in our eyes he wasn't that all the
time but he was a dad and you know what
what cool kids who want to like
shoegazing guitar playing like this is
grunge was it was just about to happen
right and it started to happen it was
like how can we be cool like that if we
got it
in our band but like he was all for it
and you know we were awful he was also
the coolest dad yeah I mean he wasn't he
wasn't a typical dad he had a foo Manchu
I think it's you know we were so into it
that it started to it started to
threaten your your passion for
basketball I would say that it that
being involved in the and the band and
then sort of you know drinking our our
own kool-aid yeah
believing that we could be rock stars
was one of the main reasons I ended up
going to state and not pursuing a
basketball a college basketball career
which would have not been a state by the
way would have been in a small school
but yeah that was one of the we were I
was like I kind of just tired a
basketball we're gonna be rock stars you
know but and we want to be clip we
wanted to be close so we're like we're
gonna go to state cuz it's in Raleigh we
can continue being a part of the band
was the thing like gigs in order to
start the band and play at the Maranatha
cafe it had to be a Christian band now
did we really want to be in a Christian
band even though we were like like all
in Christians I'd say the answer's no
I'd say we we never listen to Christian
music we were very self we're very self
away it we've always been very
self-aware but we got we had this we
felt like we thought Christian music
sucks it was second rate we're like you
know it's like I mean I don't listen to
I listen to the Red Hot Chili Peppers
Christian music anything I was told that
I shouldn't listen to him because it was
sexualized but Christian music seemed
like sort of a bad imitation of good
secular music it was and so we were just
like why no and so we were a little bit
hesitant to call ourselves Christians
'ok but it was very much christian music
let me tell you had to be every sin
order to get on that state every single
song had a Christian message and then we
would close many of our concerts with
doing something which is called an
invitation which is where you invite the
people who are at your concert to make a
decision to invite Jesus into their
hearts to become Christians at the end
of the concert and you get everybody to
pray this would happen
wax paper dogs concert and a lot of
times it would be up to me because I was
the lead singer and I mean just imagine
me and like the security circuitous way
that I communicate and take the long way
around everything and like you let a lot
of people astray when I give a speech
when I give a speech your analogies your
analogies were choice it's whenever I
give a speech is I'm hanging on by a
thread yeah and I and I can only imagine
how everybody felt now I mean while
we're on the topic of like the
embarrassing aspects of this I remember
the first song that we tried to write
before we asked Benny to officially help
us we were at Eric Woodruff's house
organic soup organic soup I actually
still have the lyrics that we wrote
because I wrote him on a paper plate a
white paper plate that was like in
Eric's bonus room it was soup organic
soup creation is the story of our God's
amazing glory creation tells the truth
that leaves all men without excuse to
explain is what they try no it's simply
the story of God's amazing glory
creation to the truth that leaves out
man except without excuse God's
existence they deny to explain is what
they try where they ever why can't they
just believe and it was a song against
the evolution yeah yeah it was a
creation song evolution vs. God why
can't they just believe in God right
don't believe in evolution that was the
first thing we chose to write a song
yeah let me go I will and I was horribly
ardent we never performed we never
performed it because we realize how that
how it wasn't just we weren't
embarrassed about the message we were
the song was bad musically like Benny
listening to that song in his life I've
got some songs that I wrote in the 70s
yes that y'all can play and why don't we
do some covers he was the first guy who
was like why don't we just do like I can
see clearly now the rain is gone like
let's sing some cover listen country
road
it's changed West Virginia in North
Carolina how about that and that was the
first that was oh this is how a song is
structured and then a few months later
we started writing our own songs we're
gonna have to move at a faster pace
we're spending a lot of time zone wax
paper dolls there's a lot of elements to
this story yeah I don't want this to be
a seven-hour podcast yeah but so that's
the frame of mine that we're in we were
the band we got better musically we
started this having this weird sort of
like sort of a 311 pop punk kind of it
was it was a great we would play at
Christian festivals and even into as we
graduated high school into our freshmen
our freshman year in college we still
play we still had gig with the band we'd
go back home and we play those gigs by
our sophomore year well let's break it
up and hear and there's a reason for
that so we get we go to NC State now my
brother had been involved with a campus
ministry called Campus Crusade for
Christ while he was at UNC and he was
actually going into his senior year and
we were going into our freshman year and
he had been really involved with them
and had gone on trips with them and was
in Bible studies and this is a huge part
of his life when he was in college and
it was a very fruitful experience and
kind of like it was really again it was
the most important part of his college
experience we visited him in a few
different places and we kind of got a
glimpse of how cool it seemed it was him
it was it was a it was it was really
cool excited to see a group of people
who were older than you college students
who were like passionately engaged with
something that was bigger than
themselves that was inspirational
and it was like oh these people aren't
just going off and you know partying on
the weekends they're there they're going
to getting together and trying to change
their lives and change other people's
lives this seems meaningful this seems
good so we were like we're gonna be
involved in Campus Crusade for Christ
when we get to NC State
now Campus Crusade for Christ as an
organization had been around since 1951
yeah it was a global organization it
still is it's now called Cru because I
think the association with a crusade is
there are some negative comments in that
story connotation
but for us freshman year at NC State we
knew that first week we were going to go
to the meeting the weekly meeting yeah
and we go to the weekly meeting about a
hundred hundred and fifty students
gathered into just packed into a
classroom and a guy gets up there
actually he didn't he wasn't even up
there yet a video starts playing it's
the very beginning of this thing and
it's like a comedic video of a guy
trying to get to the meeting yeah and it
was just blowing our minds we were like
dick you this is so awesome
this is so funny and then all of a
sudden he was on the roof he was on the
roof and then he jumped off the roof but
then they threw a mannequin off the roof
the mannequin is in the parking lot and
then it they jump cut - he's he's not a
mannequin anymore and he's wrestling
with an inflatable alligator this is
1996 you got to understand how
impressive this movie's video skills
were and so he went through this series
of obstacles yeah and then you see the
the the front of the building and you
see him finally running in the same door
that we just walked in and sat down it's
got the same clothes on the videos and
yeah as if he just came out of the video
he comes in the room and he's the emcee
of the meet and his name was Garrett I
don't remember his last name but he was
so funny he had he had the crowd just by
a string or whatever they're saying that
I'm looking for is right there
he was again I want to do it wasn't that
we didn't think that the whole spiritual
Christian aspect of what was going on
there was important but we did not
expect there to be this guy who
basically came up there and was like
David Letterman all of a sudden with a
group of a hundred kids over the next
few weeks they would do different things
like Garrett and another guy would would
sit down behind a table and they would
do they would do announcements and they
would do them like Saturday Night Live's
day we can update which we we grew up
worshiping we can update and let me
explain it wasn't just that that was
what the meaning was the meaning was
also what we called praise and worship
music where somebody would get up there
with a guitar and lead you through
Christian music everybody would sing
together passionate
then there would be some announcements
then there would be a speaker it was
usually like a local pastor or somebody
else who worked on staff with Campus
Crusade for Christ who would get up
there and do essentially a talk slash
sermon that was an inspirational and
then you sing some more music and you'd
go home and it was the best part of our
week by a long shot
now I specifically remember thinking
when Garrett was up there the very first
time I want to do that there is all I
was thinking was I want to be that guy
hmm
I want to do this now some we got
involved we got to know a guy named Mark
Valentine who's still a good friend who
was a Bible study leader he's also he
was on staff with Campus Crusade so he
he he worked and by staff when he worked
full-time his full-time job right was on
campus working with students leading
Bible studies which of which we
eventually joined his weekly Bible study
yeah and we loved mark and still do and
he was cool laid-back funny super
relatable to us in our experience yeah
and he was also at the time in charge of
the weekly meeting or at least had a I
don't know if it was because at some
point Todd became in charge of it but I
think Mark was maybe exclusively in
charge at that point anyway mark was the
guy to talk to if you wanted to be
Garrett and as Garrett was a senior we
found that out and I remember some time
that freshman year I just told mark I
was like you know and let me in for
context at this point it wasn't like me
and you were like a comedy duo we were
best friends who were both funny but we
were in a band but it wasn't like hey
the two of us are gonna go to him it
what it wasn't like that that wasn't the
dynamic I just was like I want to be
this guy in the end the thing that I did
at the same time in parallel because we
weren't talking I remember I was aware
of what you were doing and I was in full
supportive I thought it was a great idea
I was I was very hopeful at the same
time at the same meetings I was like
there's people up there leading music
you
I'm a lead singer of a band I look weird
but I could probably get up there
because I had like bleached hair and I
didn't I didn't quite fit in but I kind
of liked that and I was like there's all
these people out here I can get up there
I'm comfortable singing in front of
people so I'll join that I'll join that
music I'll join the music team right so
I did that at the exact same time so and
I did I believe in everything that was
happening yes but I will whether they're
also attracted to being in front of that
audience absolutely yeah well and the
thing is is that mark responded to this
and I don't think there was a lot of
people in line coming up to him and
saying no I want to do this and I don't
remember exactly what I said but it was
probably something along the lines of I
want to do this and I will be really
good at it it's the it's that yes the
blind delusion that we had that led us
to start a band even though we were
horrible and that led you to start
playing guitar and writing songs
immediately it's like just to blind
confidence so fast-forward to sophomore
year we that very first meeting were you
already getting them in the band at that
point okay yeah so very first meeting
I'm the MC links leading worship and I
have to assume that we went ahead and
made a video for that first meeting
because we had were seen we had seen
that precedent set by a garret I don't
remember exactly but I I know that I
have all of the videos so we'll meet we
can unearth these videos and take a look
at him and well you know we'll find a
way to share them with you over time but
what we did was our sophomore year is
when we moved into an apartment with
Greg no no that was junior that was
junior year yeah we just we got to know
Greg freshman year and then we became
good friends
sophomore year because we were still was
still in Syme dorm sophomore so did he
did he start out as like the sidekick
yeah I don't know if that started from
day one
but essentially I had a very specific
plan for what I wanted the sort of the
openings to be like and again it this is
the the this this has been sort of
outlined by the previous MC but I was
like the more that this can be like a
late-night show and a monologue the
better right and so there's a couple of
different conventions that kind of
evolved over that first year including
Greg we've talked about Greg a lot our
college roommate in junior year but it
was just a really good friend and our
sophomore year became like the Andy
Richter to Conan or yeah you know just
he was like a sidekick character and he
would get up there and he would have
what a deep thought every single week
yeah he would say after much deep
thought and great meditation I've come
to the realization that and then he
would say something that was really
really dumb really dumb really really
stupid and everybody would laugh and
then he would sit up there and just kind
of respond to you for the rest of your
monologue or whenever you were
introducing and I in this is listen I
was not I was studying a lot I was in
engineering school I was studying a lot
but I was putting a lot of time into
that monologue and what it would be in
like okay I'm gonna tell this story
about something that happened or I'm
gonna I've got this interesting scenario
that I'm gonna talk about and then I
introduced the word of the day which was
okay tonight during the monologue if I
say the word dog I want everybody to
respond with uh-huh and so then I would
have my monologue and I would have that
word tour at eat up a few different
times in so there would be this like
call and response for all these people
were going oh and I just I lived for
this I also lived for it as well as Greg
the three of us I remember I would be
working with Greg on his deep thought
and like helping him practice it because
that was his moment and you know helping
him write it all three of us would do
that and we tried more often than not to
also have a video and I had taken an
intro to film course right and we had
that video camera that we had used some
in high school I guess it was the same
one I think it was still the one that it
was my dad's camera that we basically
just commandeered yeah
and I was I was basically the cameraman
/ director of all of these videos that
we would make that would feature you and
Greg and I base it I usually wouldn't be
in them because I'll be filming the
whole thing and then you would edit all
of these videos on to VCRs yeah you
would film it and again this is back
when mrs. before there was any sort of
software editing that we knew of so I'd
take those mini DV tapes I'd go to my
dad's office a camel University because
he was a law professor at Campbell and
cook to DV it's VCRs up and edit them
together and then put popular music edit
popular music and usually Led Zeppelin
yeah yeah just just for contests
sometimes are only some ones which
that's that's the problem with sharing
it we can't put it on YouTube because it
has so much Led Zeppelin on it we just I
don't know if we can do that just a
couple couple of notes first of all this
is gonna be a two-parter I can already
tell unless you want this to be a
two-hour thing I got over 40 minutes in
and we haven't even gotten out of
college yet that's fine I think that's
okay
so let's just keep going it okay that
we're going hopefully you'll appreciate
that
I'm having fun the second thing is again
I want to shout out mark Valentine for a
mic Mahaffey and Mike Mahaffey who was
the the director of Campus Crusade still
is at NC State we'll talk more about
Mike in a second but both of them
letting us do this they took a chance
and listen we pushed we pushed the
limits I mean I remember there was one
video you know what I'm talking about
we had conceptualized this thing they
didn't even they didn't review the
videos ahead of time I don't think and
this one you and Greg the story was you
had forgotten about the weekly meeting
right and so you and instead you were
playing video games in Greg's dorm room
which is something we often did but
twisted metal is our game but we thought
it would be funnier if the story was
whenever you guys would play video games
you were always completely naked right
so for this scene you were playing
twisted metal in his dorm room
completely naked yeah and of course we
didn't give a [ __ ]
you were completely nuts it you think
you yanked up my briefs I yanked up my
briefs
I love how in your memory oh is that
what I did I know we wouldn't have cared
but there was like controllers or
different things like Austin Powers like
I remember like a backpack being given
and it would always you giclee place
cover the job this may seem incongruous
with a Christian ministry a relatively
conservative Christian ministry but I
just want to say and again this is to
credit the guys involved it's like it
was all in good fun it was all
light-hearted there was no actual
nakedness it was just okay it was the
idea of nakedness and you know we didn't
cross the line I'm sure there was some
people there that a lot of us a little
too close to the pubes I will say that
well what I'll say it was also the late
90s and it was a little bit different I
think now I actually think it would be
less likely that that kind of video
would but it was a different time in
comedy yeah and that was in that was
influencing us and also they just let us
they let us learn like you know again we
were we were growing in our faith in in
big ways it was very serious to us and
we were very involved and we were going
on trips we were going on these things
called summer projects yeah I'll impact
that a little bit but but at the same
time because this continued for the next
three years sophomore year junior year
and senior year emceeing this meeting
and putting more and more work into
making it something that people had to
go to and I think there's a lot of
different reasons for you know it wasn't
just because of what we were doing the
weekly meeting the weekly meeting began
to grow though and that audience of a
hundred 150 turned into an audience of a
thousand and it was like this is yeah
all of a sudden this just became such a
big part getting up in front of that
group and entertaining them became
something that I just began to fall in
love with it was so rewarding and I mean
I was I was
it's so invested in it as well I
remember
consider myself the chief laugher like
whenever I'd sit down from like singing
the music whenever it was time for like
what we plan to be funny it's like I was
I was laughing louder than anybody you
know and we didn't sing many songs then
but I remember the first song we sang
was when the seniors were graduating and
it was so we wrote a song for the
graduating seniors and we wrote this
like mysterious mythological song about
a guy called mr. senior it was even by
well even by late night news standards
politically incorrect
yeah because well but you so you sing
the song you play a guitar but then you
had backup singer I had a backup singer
who was a guy with three heads when it
was me Greg and our other good friend
who became our roommate Tim all in one
t-shirt together with our heads sticking
out of it singing backup and it was like
kind of added like a Spanish theme like
get it mr. senior mr. senior mr. senior
mr. senior uh we wouldn't do it today we
didn't understand the sensitivities at
the time and people just thought it was
funny but it was I mean we live for that
meaning because this this audience was
growing it was the it was the largest
meeting on campus yeah over a thousand
people were showing up and it was again
for a variety of reasons but it was it
was so much fun it was so rewarding to
have that audience and so you can start
to see how you you developed a style and
and a tone and I think the the because
video became such a big part of our
careers moving forward this really was
the beginning of us figuring out mm-hmm
how to make an audience laugh with video
because you can have an idea that
something's gonna be funny when you sit
and watch it and just you the two of us
but creating something and then having a
thousand pee
watch it we cut our teeth men on
figuring out what makes what first of
all it probably wasn't even that funny
if we went back and watched on these
videos we'd be like why in the world did
we think this was funny but we were
learning and very much comedic ly
developing now one of the things that
happen senior year Mike Mahaffey the
director of the whole ministry again is
another just one of the best guys we've
ever known who was getting a kick out of
what we were doing at the weekly meeting
he was the director of the Christmas
conference we called it at the time it
had to call it winter conference now the
regional conference where it's not only
NC State students with along with
Meredith and peace peace students but it
was all the surrounding states Campus
Crusade movements would all come
together after Christmas for a week
he was North Carolina North Carolina
South Carolina Tennessee Kentucky and
West Virginia does that sound right
yeah well he's part of yeah yeah and so
there would be over a thousand students
that would show up at that every year so
he directed the main stage of that and
chose who was gonna be the emcee right
so we've been going to Christmas
conference again every single year a
significant portion of our Christmas
break was going to this conference and
they all they had people who were
full-time staff with Campus Crusade were
the only people who were seeing the
meetings so I remember a guy Shane Daiki
yeah I don't know if it was it he was he
big breaker was he Christmas coach
somebody I can't remember who there was
a few different people who MC but they
were like doing what I was doing at the
weekly meeting but doing it on a whole
different level and it was just like
this is awesome but I didn't think it
wasn't even on the radar to try to emcee
that because I'm out on staff I'm a
student right Mike Mahaffey comes to me
my senior year and says what do you
think about emceeing Christmas
conference
I mean I probably almost crapped my
pants when eaten when he asked me that
of course I was like yes sir I never say
no always say yes to the opportunity
okay yeah we come to find out later that
Mike really had to go to bat for you to
do that he took a big risk and I think
there was a lot of criticism and you
know for him for the decision he made
and he had to convince a lot of people
to to give you the opportunity to do
that and if it wasn't for that moment we
would not be here right now no not I
mean I would say if it wasn't for every
moment that you talked about but there's
such a pivotal one but this one this one
thing where my Mahaffey asked me to
emcee the Christmas conference set in
motion a course of events that very
directly led to what we're doing today
that will continue to unpack so I
remember hearing about it and I was just
floored and so got it we got to get a
better camera and so while the weekly
meeting is you know the weekly meeting
every week was just like okay you're
gonna get up there you're gonna talk for
5 to 10 minutes and then you're gonna
basically introduce the speaker and that
kind of thing and then maybe give some
announcements this was like no no no
you're like there's a morning session
there's an afternoon session it lasts
like five days you're gonna be up there
you're gonna you're not just introduced
you're like introducing like this
big-time pastor all of a sudden you know
Tom Nelson al Mohler right hey you know
and we just all of sudden we knew that
this was a different level of
responsibility and the preparation went
into overdrive we had multiple videos we
see this is the first time that we this
is when we really started writing songs
funny songs for an audience the first
year I think the only thing we did was I
wrote the the Christmas conference saw
him basically the conference song and I
don't I don't even know like you help
with the videos I don't know if you got
up there for the Christmas cover song at
that first year I don't I think I did I
can't remember the
I think I think I think I think harmony
okay because like we were we were
writing those songs together it's not
like we hadn't written songs even in
high school together so yeah it was like
the end of the week we wrote a the song
kind of summarized everything that
happened that week it was like a series
of inside jokes that was the first song
that we ever performed at a conference
and we both did it right and crowd loved
it and then proceeded to emcee this
conference for ten years in a row just
to give you an example of how big of a
swath this was because that year the
first one was 99 I remember we had to
stop the conference usually the
conference would go through New Year's
rocked the conference shortened sent
everybody home on the 31st because it
was y2k and everyone thought the world
was going to end well no it wasn't like
it was like some religious belief there
was a practical belief that like he
didn't know if like utilities were gonna
go down because of the way you work so
you didn't want to have all these
college students stranded in a
neighboring state there was a lot of
fear about y2k not from a religious damn
right it was from a technical standpoint
but it was like we got to get these
students home so the conference was a
year shorter but then just to kind of
make truncate this a little bit over the
next couple of years your involvement
began to increase
you were always involved with the music
and you're always involved with the
videos but you started getting up on
stage and I would say I don't remember
exactly what year it was but this is
just a little bit of the evolution of
how we became rhettandlink I'd say three
to four conferences in you were just up
there from the beginning and we were
doing it together yeah we probably had
to stop talking about that and talk
about like okay well what's happening
vocationally at this time like
professionally what are we trying to do
because the Christmas conference thing
continued on so so it's probably best to
talk about what we did after we
graduated yeah and
you know we've talked about how much of
an outlet Campus Crusade provided for us
to to engage an audience and also
develop especially you at this point
develop as a comedian and for us to
develop as like creators but personally
some so much of our college experience
was wrapped up in our involvement in
Campus Crusade if we if it if it wasn't
friends that we had or acquaintances we
had through our studies in our
engineering curriculum basically all of
our friends definitely all of our
closest friends were just as involved in
campus crusade as we were and that meant
we were involved in every single aspect
of it yeah you know there was the Bible
study every week you talk about Mark
Valentine and the impact he had on our
lives like he would meet with us and
talk about like you know going through
break up with my high school girlfriend
and like all the heart-wrenching stuff
that you try to that you have to go
through when you're discovering who you
are in college and all of the potential
pitfalls associated with that it's like
oh you know I can't thank him and the
organization enough for providing an
environment for us to develop who we
were in every way possible yeah that was
extremely positive it was it was a and
we've alluded to our college experience
in general terms and you can you can
filter that through everything we're
saying today that like it was it was an
amazing thrilling time in our lives who
we were a part of something bigger than
ourselves and also really looking at
ourselves and how we can develop as
people that do things that matter well
and more specifically because again
we've established that okay we're not in
the same place as we were at the time
like the way we think about the world is
not the same that it was as women were
in college but that does not change the
fact that our involvement with Cru and
guys like might have a more Valentine
Todd Smith it was incredibly
instrumental in
sort of understanding what it meant to
be a person of integrity you know I'm
saying like Thalia not that you can't
have integrity or character outside of
the system like that but it was like we
were growing as people really like in an
accelerated rate and honestly when we
looked around and a lot of our peers in
college there's a lot of them at what
that wasn't happening it just kind of
felt like I'm just I'm just here for the
I'm just here for fun and we were like
I'm here for purpose you know and this
is this is something that's so that is
so much bigger than me and it's bigger
than just my life and it's bigger than
just this group and it's bigger than
just the earth this was like a universal
purpose and all having all these people
because you're when you're that age like
18 to 21 you are at you you had your
your potential for being passionate
about things is as high as it ever will
be trust makes oh yeah it's gonna go
down just gonna go down but 18 to 21 boy
it is on fire and it was just being
being associated with a an organization
like that at that time it was just super
instrumental and and kind of forming us
into who we are
yeah I mean we were we would go to the
fall retreat we would go to the
Christmas conference and from the
Christmas conference they would say you
can spend your entire summer on a thing
called summer project we both responded
to that I spent an entire summer as a
student in Santa Cruz California which
is where I participated in the 70s dance
contest that's on this t-shirt that
we're selling at mythical calm right now
yeah it's crazy and that's why you went
to Slovakia you know you talked about
being in Slovakia and like being and
like writing letters to Jessie because
you had just started almost dating yeah
Christine went on summer project to
Santa Cruz the year after me and we were
corresponding when she got back the
night she got back is when we got
engaged we Christi and I met
well you can Jessi met a little bit
differently but we met a church Chrissy
and I met through Campus Crusade she was
a student at Meredith she came to those
weekly meetings she saw me helping lead
the music she was interested she joined
the music team partially because she was
kind of wanted to get to know me you
know it was every so many the majority
of the aspects of who we were who were
being built to be and who we were
becoming was through the context of
Campus Crusade so it was such a
meaningful thing that when we were
graduating well I felt like I feel it's
necessary to acknowledge there's another
side of it too for other people yeah if
you're listening to this talk about this
and you were involved in the campus
ministry whether was Campus Crusade or
another one you may think very
differently about your time there right
right you may have been a time of
spiritual trauma for you that's the case
with a lot of people especially a lot of
women because they're even to this day
there tend to be very particular roles
that are expected of men and women and
conservative Christian circles like the
ones that we were involved with and so
it may seem sort of like insensitive for
us to talk about like even though we
don't really we're not there anymore and
this isn't the way we think about the
world to talk about it as if it was
these glory days and everything was
great and we were growing and all this
stuff it really was like that for us
because it was an environment that was
really really set up well for people
like us to sort of flourish and succeed
but there was a lot that we didn't know
and there I'm sure there were people who
were suffering and I'm sure that there
were people especially a lot of women
who might look back and be like I
actually looked back at that time and I
feel very differently about it so just
want to acknowledge that and I'm glad
you did I I see all that really just
just set the stage for what our mindset
not not what it is now but what it was
when we graduate not to mention live
I'll add one more thing not to mention
people
you know LGBT people which was not on
our radar at all coming from where we
came from but we know that there were
LGBT people in crusade who were you know
if they were going in and they were
really getting involved then that was
not that was something that was not
being supported in any way and I think
that it wasn't something that was on our
radar I mean you're hinting at topics
that we do want to that we will talk
about in in in over the next few
episodes yeah so but I I'm glad that
you're seeing it now because it's
important that we're not painting this
picture of something that there's not a
flip side to it and yeah that we haven't
had evolved views on since that point
and we will get into them we'll get into
all that in a subsequent episode I'm
really we're really trying to keep this
more like the logistics connecting the
dots from a career standpoint right but
from a from a belief standpoint and like
personal impact good and bad yeah I
think those are things that we can talk
about we will talk about later but a lot
of people have a tendency to when they
kind of come out of a deeply religious
environment they just talk a bunch of
[ __ ] about it and you know we'll talk
our fair share [ __ ] about it at some
point but I think that the reality is is
that it was it really is it contributed
so much to who we are and the way we
move in the world and especially the way
that we kind of have carried out our
careers so that's that's why we talk
about it with the level of fondness
because I still have a lot of love and
respect for a lot of the people who are
were and are involved so when we
graduated you know I I graduated I mean
he got married I technically had another
semester but yeah a season I'll make
that another lost lost year podcast
years from now no it's not really
anything there but basically where do
you want it where do you want to end
this one because we're in an hour right
now I kind of feel like we just got
through college
and then we've got
oh we basically got a lot of details to
fill in from graduating and then getting
to YouTube yeah I think this is a this
is a good place to put a pin in it until
next week I will say that the big
question that people who see where we
are now like journalists or whatnot want
to ask is or just the most obvious
question that people want to ask is how
did you make a decision to go from from
to quit your jobs as engineers to to
then go into full-time entertainment
like to make that risk to make that leap
that had to be scary how did you make
that jump and actually the the bigger
issue with us was at this at this
juncture in our lives it was you know
given our involvement here and there's
some opportunity and there's a there's a
pull to us continue to want to to be a
part of this organization and to also
develop and to to have an audience
versus just being engineers and so there
was a few years of working through that
which I think will be the starting point
yeah of the next episode that was some
of the biggest decisions that we ever
made in our lives and our careers as
families as friends were made in in that
juncture because you got to remember
this is the year this is happening in
2000 if you think about YouTube didn't
even exist until late 2005 practically
for like for people to be aware of it
2006 you know it's like so if we're
graduating college and YouTube doesn't
even even exist for five or six years
what did we do in order to bridge that
gap in order to position ourselves so
that we could take advantage of this
thing we didn't even know was going to
be there you know we weren't just
engineers and then we just quit yeah and
became intern attainder it was a little
more not why I'm happier than that at
all there's five years and the things
that we
it may blow your mind and we're gonna
talk about them next week so I mean I
don't I I'm trying to figure out how I
feel at this point I I got I've got a
little bit of a charge out of this
I feel wired I feel that way I feel like
I just know it's not all out this is
good when it's all out this is such a I
don't know it's just there's a lot of
the things that we're talking about are
pretty explosive for people you know and
it's just like that that's just the
reality this is the this is as personal
as it gets for a lot of people is you
know what you think about the bigger
deeper things in life and your opinions
about those and who you associate with
and the group's you're involved in my
only regret is that we haven't
incorporated more politics into this
first no it's so yeah I I have this I
want to keep going and maybe we'll keep
recording but we'll keep recording we're
gonna be in the same outfits from we're
just gonna start another episode in a
second I'm sorry you gotta wait a week
but this will give you an opportunity to
use hashtag ear biscuits to be a part of
the conversation log your thoughts any
questions that are popping up for you
and again we're gonna be logging those
and it'll be a while before we have an
opportunity to address them in a way
that you can hear it but go ahead and
and do that now and we'll talk at you
next week well I'm gonna go have a wreck
oh we can just get the wreck I come
because I'm very excited beholden to it
okay no I've been excited about this for
a while and I'm gonna I'm gonna read
about it because I want to get it right
so I found a podcast called the 1619
podcast this is a limited audio series
from the New York Times's are observing
the 400th anniversary of the beginning
of American slavery here's a little
description in August of 1619 a ship
carrying more than 20 enslaved Africans
arrived in the English colony of
Virginia America was not yet America but
this was the moment it began no aspect
of the country that would be formed here
has been untouched by the 250 years of
slavery that followed on the 400th
anniversary of this fateful moment
it is time to tell the story 16:19 is a
New York Times audio series hosted by
Nicole Hannah Jones you can find more
information about it at newyorktimes.com
or nytimes.com slash 16:19 podcasts now
I just think you ought to listen to this
if I believe it should be required
listening for every American and anybody
else in the world who just wants to kind
of understand the reality of you know
the history of slavery and then racism
towards black people in America it's
just there's a lot of things you don't
hear in your history books there's a lot
of things that the way that things were
framed and frankly whitewashed to go
down easy for the majority of people
that that's what we learned and that's
the way that we learned about a lot of
these things but in you know as somebody
who grew up in the south and kind of
went into adulthood
thinking that like oh yeah I mean racism
and like that's cut that stuff's kind of
in that was in the past I mean that
America used to be that way it's pretty
eye-opening and enlightening of course I
don't I didn't think that before I
listened to this podcast I I changed my
ideas about that a long time ago but I
think that this is super illuminating
very very well done and it's only about
five or six episodes and you can be
completely done with it so 1619 podcast
check it out
all right we'll speak at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]